Today is google developer program engineer Araki 1
is
Today I will talk on the theme of ux anti pattern
x Anti-pattern is a disappointing ui ux that is often found in low-rated apps
It is
This time I will mainly talk about apps other than games
For each anti-pattern, url of the corresponding page of the official document
Please see together by all means because it has been described
Let's first look at anti-patterns related to dialog
Frequent display of dialogs representing read-in seems to be hated by the user
It is frustrating if reading is late and can not be canceled
Even if reading is fast, the entire screen flickers, so I'm worried
Place a progress bar below the action bar instead
In the part where content is displayed from now
It would be better to display the animation being read directly, etc.
Application book where button position is different from os standard
You see often When the positive option is on the right in android 4.0 or later
It is determined
The Blanc example dialog is what appears after the user presses the delete button.
The only choice is to make a positive justification
is
Next, let's look at the operability on the touch screen
I still see apps that buttons are too small to push
The touchable area should basically be 48 bp or more for both vertical and horizontal
It is a useless pattern that there is no feedback in the touch area
Visual feedback is important as there is no touch on the touch screen
Change the color if you touch the button so that you can see which part will respond
Let's go
In addition, when you press the button, the bar will appear on the flower screen.
It takes some time for the screen to switch, no matter how much speed is up
It will get frustrating if you don't know if it's done for a short while
Let's put in touch feedback properly
ui design is not just to write
The attraction of the content that should have been the leading role in ui that was overworked and tedious
Will be difficult to communicate
Also the design looks inconsistent with the design and the app looks like a flatfish android standard
Let's customize based on the design
Furthermore, even if the design is focused on pixel units, it will collapse if the screen size changes
It's messed up with the multi-screen support provided by the android framework
Learn the mechanism and let's design it for use in various screen sizes from the beginning
In the world of app design that continues to evolve every day, there is no win in the app that rewards rent
Hmm
menu button of shame is android 2.3
This is a button to simulate the previous menu key with a new start
As it is only for compatibility with old apps
It is quite disappointing that this button still appears in the app released in the past year
Hmm
The correspondence is just to have the target sdk version of the manifest updated.
Flick the target sdk version to support Frey terminal
Is a mistake
Basically always keep it up-to-date
Do not use the gingerbread era style anymore
In the example shown, it is a button progress bar seek bar but all targets sdk
You can use the new style just by updating the version and digging the theme
Using the design for other platforms to make the android app
let's stop
It looks very common in Japanese apps, but the design to place the tab bar below is
not android
Tabs are to be placed on top in android
In some cases, it is possible to switch by side swipe and navigation drawing wow
Use
Let's create an app that looks like android
Right-handed cullet with list cone is android style
not
No caret like the standard setting screen is the android style
I sometimes see apps that use a different navigation method than the standard
For example, sometimes there is an app displaying a bar like the one shown at the top of the screen
This is not an android standard design
The default is to use the action bar as shown below and the setting is basically
Put in the action bar overflow menu
Cash on delivery
Jason is standard at the same time and originality is demonstrated in the functions and content of the app
Let's go
Don't implement your own shared functionality with no particular meaning
Sns without using the system standard intent sharing function as shown in the screen
There is an application that allows users to log in and arrange their own post button
Unless it is an application that takes a close relationship with a specific sns.
System standard sharing features should be easier for users
Easy to implement for developers
It is not recommended to make app ui in leg view
Just wrap the web app in web view just to bring it up to the play store
Apps that are in the form of apk at will receive low ratings from users
As long as you use it appropriately to display the content
Web view is convenient, but all buttons and menus are created in web view
There are limits in terms of ease of use and performance as well.
It is hated by the user after all
Unless it takes time to load even through 3d games etc.
The splash screen is only annoying for the user
Branding is done on the action bar and content, not on the splash screen
Let's go
Also, when you try to close the application with the back key, there is something to confirm permanently
It's not an irreversible distance to quit the app, so you need to ask the user
It will not be
Please refer to the url you see for details.
One when there are multiple notifications of the same type
Let's put together
I also often see apps that only assume usage of vertical phone
Many people use the phone sideways
Also in the last 12 years, the proportion of tablet devices has become non-negligible
Android framework for various terminals using fragments etc
Because there is a mechanism to create ui efficiently beforehand, it will be surprising to try it actually
it's simple
Let's look at the minute problems that you often see
The notification icon displayed in the status bar by android standard
It is a thing
Recently the number of terminals of xxhdpi has increased
Are the images for high resolution and high resolution properly aligned?
Also, the icons do not have to be in the same shape
Let's put out your personality
We talked a lot, but let's make it an action bar
Navigation is basically an application using the android framework
As long as you are making most things that will form naturally and properly
Design the app without understanding it properly and receive the ball that the shop does not originally need store day
Also from the top user rating
It will be difficult if it will be one song android standard design guide
It is a shortcut to a highly rated app to refine the design based on the guidelines
Thank you for watching